you all know about Airbnb right you guys
know about Airbnb well it's a website if
you don't know where you can rent out
your house your apartment or your spare
bedroom to travelers who don't want to
stay in a hotel and you know we here at
the show we're always looking for ways
to make a little extra cash or or yeah
why not
so I thought of a great living space
that's right here in our studio and it's
totally underutilized I'm talking about
our rafters okay yeah think about this
this is true their spacious they're
available they're relatively safe you
know I think we haven't looked into that
so this is a true story a couple of days
ago I listed our rafters here here at
Warner Brothers Studios in Burbank on
air B&B this is it this is real we
listed and we promised we promised that
two lucky winners would get to spend the
night up there well we got thousands and
thousands of entries this morning we
picked the winners their names are I got
them right here on a blue card and this
is exciting
Andrea and Nick flowers from Shawnee
Oklahoma
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how is it up there creaking yeah all
right just don't move around a lot we're
trying not sir you guys now is this
right Andrea when you got the call Nick
as though is it Nick who signed up who
signed you up I signed up and I didn't
tell my husband you didn't tell him now
so we called you guys today and Nick
picked up and Nick you thought it was a
prank right right
okay are you happy about this are you
happy that you'll be spending the night
in the rafters of our studio I guess so
I don't really have let's check out your
accommodations let's see we got there
there are beds we put cots up there can
you see the cops to hook up that they've
been up there since the 1940s literally
dozens of aspiring young actresses were
impregnated on those very cards so you
guys also have a bathroom let's check
out their bathroom right there it is
yeah yeah that's here's the problem
that's not hooked up to anything so wait
till after the show to use it cuz stuff
will drop directly on this guy right
here I think up there there's a raccoon
broom for you up there yeah this place
is lousy with raccoons and best of all
look who's near by guys look at that
that's where la Bamba sleeps
thank God it's not a necessary
instrument all right congratulations
guys and you're gonna be here for the
whole show I'm gonna enjoy it up there I
think I bet you they do it up there
she's laughing he isn't all right I
don't know what that means
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please